no
[Música]
aquí y ahora soy aquí y ahora estoy
lance
el aquí y el ahora es el único momento
que realmente existe
un momento donde podemos ser felices y
conseguir esa bienestar que cada ser
humano está buscando
en el aquí y en el ahora es que
conseguimos la conexión esa conexión de
el momento presente el regalo de estar
tan solo existir
tengo técnicas y herramientas que me han
llevado a un aprendizaje personal que
hoy vengo a compartir para que cada
quien consiga su técnica y sus
herramientas
en mi caso fue el yoga desde muy pequeña
ha practicado está
técnica ancestral que me ha dado
flexibilidad esa es la palabra que yo
invito a que cada persona se interese a
empezar con su cuerpo buscar esa
flexibilidad que te va a dar no sólo en
el cuerpo sino en la mente y al ser
flexible en la mente después que ahora
haya más posibilidades se abre a un
mundo de posibilidades
todos los firmes rígidos pertenecen a la
muerte lo blando flexible pertenece a la
vida te invito a la vida a ser flexible
la siguiente es sonreír la sonrisa y la
técnica de sonreír y son y tener esa
sonrisa la conseguí con la meditación
meditar es ir hacia adentro cómo voy a
hacer dentro que me hace ir hacia
adentro pues la respiración es la
primera manera de aplicar esa técnica
porque la respiración es algo tan
natural en nosotros que tomamos unos
minutos para sentir es nuestro cuerpo
sentir nuestras emociones y puedes fluir
con esa respiración nos va a llevar a
esa sonrisa a esa unión con el corazón
universal a esa unión con todos los
corazones que nos llevan a sentir que
estamos conectados con algo más allá con
algo que nos une a todos la meditación
es una técnica para empezar a saber
controlar los pensamientos pues los
pensamientos la mente está acostumbrada
a pensar es lo más natural de nosotros
estar pensando entonces al tener la
técnica de meditación poco a poco nos
vamos a previendo a ser valientes de ir
hacia adentro y de entender que está en
nosotros todos están dentro de nosotros
todos
todas esas respuestas que estamos
buscando entonces realmente los invito a
ir hacia adentro a respirar a tomarse
los minutos que puedan para sentir sus
emociones y así pues sonreírle a la vida
cuando se sonríe del corazón se vive el
reencuentro con el corazón universal y
todos sonríen uno
danza y canto es la siguiente
herramienta que yo he practicado y me ha
dado un mundo de posibilidades
el canto pues un momento donde realmente
me entrego en el momento presente y no
hay nada más que exista sino esa
expresión natural innata de mí que
quiere pues expresarse no le pido a la
gente que aseguró tenía que ser cantante
y que deba puedes expresarse a través
del canto pero sí si tienes un mensaje
que dar si tienes algo que expresar está
en ti en expresar lo porque realmente
vas a hacer la diferencia cuando tú te
conectas con tu voz cada voz es perfecta
cada voz es de por sí un regalo que te
da la vida para la expresión al igual
que la danza la danza es lo más
intuitivo que tenemos es algo innato que
está dentro de nosotros donde nos
podemos expresar con libertad donde
nuestro cuerpo es nuestro vehículo para
de crear en el momento presente no
existe otra cosa el pasado ya pasó el
futuro aún no existe está en el presente
en el momento presente donde puedes
crear no te olvides de lanzar
no te olvides y fluye con la vida fluye
en el aquí y en el ahora
entonces las tres herramientas son
flexibilidad yo la consigue con el yoga
muchos años de práctica tuve la
oportunidad de estar en india me he
llevado muchos grupos por venezuela con
violeta 360 y considero que está en
conseguir tu lugar tu momento para
explorar con tu cuerpo a través de esa
práctica del yoga la siguiente sería
sonreír yo la conseguí meditando ir
hacia adentro observar dónde están esos
talentos internos esos talentos que son
innatos en ti y hacerlos brillar con tan
solo escucharte con tan solo sentirte
con tan solo soltar
y fluir sería la tercera herramienta que
les invitó a practicar fluir a través de
la danza libre está titans fue la
práctica que a mí me liberó
completamente pues me atreví me
me envalentone de sentir mi cuerpo de
soltar mi cuerpo y de fluir con la vida
eso me lleva a vivir en el ahora a vivir
en el amor en el amor universal en amar
mi cuerpo amar y ser y expresar lo
entendiendo que todo a cada quien tiene
su proceso de aprendizaje cada quien
tiene su camino que llevar y aceptando
aceptando que es aquí y ahora la
flexibilidad la sonrisa
la fluidez
son herramientas que te ayudarán a
descubrir ese talento natural que está
de ti en ti medita baile yoga atrévete a
conseguir esa felicidad la magia de
encontrar tu esencia verdadera
gracias les voy a cantar una canción un
mantra a chivas
y
llega si va a llevar una masiva
chivas chivas chivas
[Música]
y va usadas
si vas y va a llevar la masiva
la estiba sido así
llamas y varias salas y varias ciudades
y gama
mayo
siga siga
[Música]
la masiva
sardá estival
y
[Música]
a ti
sólo pisa
a mí quizás sólo quizás
[Música]
no a mí
y quizás quizás donde más y vaya bien a
más y vaya una masiva a una masiva ya
una masiva masiva ya una masiva masiva
masiva
vaya vaya vaya que sí vaya a una masiva
masiva masiva
chivas chivas chivas chivas chivas viva
él va a más y varió nada y barea
[Música]
y